bonsoir donc ce soir je vais vous
présenter
lost in the swell donc le seul c'est
quoi c'est qui c'est une asso et ses
trois potes c'est moi aurel énormément
donc sort vous pouvez voir que je suis
tout seul donc il s'excuse ils peuvent
pas être là ce soir donc on est trois
potes d'enfance
donc moi et ronan se connaît depuis la
sixième donc depuis qu'on a 12 ans ça
fait un moment 23 ans et avec nono donc
c'est le petit nom d'aurélien on se
connaît depuis quinze ans et donc on va
être passion commune le surf donc moins
rien on est les deux surfeurs de la
bande et en revenant lui et le cameraman
donkey surf un peu aussi mais pendant
nos périples il est plus d'art la caméra
et donc
la première fois on a eu envie de se
couper un peu de tout ce monde moderne
pour essayer de voir si on pouvait lier
notre passion le surf un mode de vie
plus respectueux de l'environnement et
donc on est parti essayer de survivre
pour surfer sur une île déserte
donc on est parti en or de daisy donc à
l'époque on avait comme partenaire
cannabis donc en gros ils nous ont donné
3000 euros pour partir là bas donc ça
nous a permis de nous payer les billets
d'avion et ensuite on a pris deux poules
donc clara morgane pour l'heureux on a
pris dix kilos de riz 40 kg et des
fusils de chasse pour partir chasser des
poissons donc l'idée était d'être
autonome et de voir si on pouvait rester
40 jours sur 7 il a donc en gros on a
contacté un pêcher en eau des
indonésiens qui nous a déposés sur l'île
et on lui a dit de revenir nous chercher
carouge ans plus tard donc à l'époque on
n'est vraiment pas de budget vous n'avez
pas téléphone satellite on n'a aucun
moyen de de communication et en gros
c'était pas mal mais c'est quand même
pas très bien passé donc on a eu des
bonnes vagues et en fait il a plu
beaucoup et donc on au ps sont se sont
empirées on à la fin des plus à manger
on a perdu clara morgane est la cerise
sur le gâteau on avait plus de feu donc
tous nos briques est mort et donc avec
un peu de porc n'a jamais réussi à
refaire et heureusement une tempête est
arrivée et des pêcheurs indonésiens sont
venus se réfugier sur l'île et donc on
leur a troqué tout ce qu'on avait pour
pouvoir rentrer à terre une fois rentré
vous voyez un peu la galère il pleut et
chacun essaie de faire du mieux qu'ils
pouvaient mais avec nos nos talents de
citadins on n'a pas été bien loin mais
par contre une fois qu'on est rentré
donc ronan s'est affairé à réaliser un
film
donc on a appelé désillusion donc le
petit jaune mots et qu'on a diffusé
gratuitement sous forme de web série sur
internet
donc ça plutôt pas mal marché donc on
est pas mal de mon retour et suite à ça
donc ça nous a permis de dymagym d'un
autre
un autre périple et donc de pouvoir
aller voir d'autres partenaires et avoir
un peu plus de budget pour repartir
donc en gros sur l'île c'était bien on a
pas mal galéré au niveau des moins de
transport en étant en voiture donc on
s'est rendu compte que pour accéder à
des vagues surfées l'idéal sans arrêter
d'y aller en bateau
donc pour ça on voulait apporter un
aspect environnemental donc qui
s'appelle l'éco-conception en fait ça
faisait déjà plusieurs années que je
sers fait des planches éco-conçus donc
qu'est-ce qui sait quand conception
c'est l'idée c'est de remplacer les
matières issues du pétrole par des
matières naturelles donc en l'occurrence
les planches de surf c'est fait avec de
la fibre de verre de la résine et de la
mousse de polystyrène est donc là nos
planches sont dont la fibre c'est la
fibre de lin avec une partie de la
résine qui est bio sourcés donc il fit
une matière naturelle et donc on voulait
apporter ce côté là à notre bateau est
donc pour ça on a donc d'abord réfléchi
quel modèle de bâton voulait prendre
donc on a opté pour un petit bateau avec
un fief faible tirant d'eau c'est à dire
qu'on pouvait aller vraiment au plus
près des spots de surf sans toucher les
cailloux donc pour ceindre rencontré
antoine audet à droite donc qui est le
directeur du chantier naval tri cat et
on a été également voir roland jourdain
qui à gauche qui est un navigateur
reconnue donc il a gagné deux fois la
route du rhum et qui est surtout très
influent un très impliqué pardon dans
tout ce qui est justement environnement
les parties éco-conception et donc avec
son entreprise kairos qui du coup s'est
spécialisée là dedans et
nous a donné un bateau qui s'appelle
goualade donc en gros c'était le premier
trimaran éco-conçus du genre donc on a
prié le modèle de bateau donc trick at
classic et donc roland jourdain a
apporté toute la partie éco conception
l'idée c'est pareil vous pouvez voir là
donc toutes les parties maru en fait
c'est la fibre de lin qui apparente et
donc toute la fibre de verre est
remplacé par la fibre de lin et
participe bateau est également en fait
fait en liège
donc avant de nous quand on d'inscrits
dès qu on a été voir roland jourdain
c'était de partir aux îles salomon donc
toujours à la recherche de vague un sort
fait à la rencontre des populations
et quand il nous a demandé quel était
notre expérience en navigation on lui a
dit que ce n'était pas bien grande donc
en gros run en lui avait déjà un peu
navigué sur le bateau de ses parents
moi j'avais fait un peu optimiste mais
n'était jamais sortie de la rade de
brest et pour aurélien il n'avait jamais
mis le pied sur un voilier l'habilleuse
à regarder des grands diesel et 10 pour
les gars ça serait bien de vous faire un
peu le pied marin est d'abord de faire
le tour de la bretagne avant de partir à
l'autre bout du monde donc c'est ce
qu'on a fait on a fait pour la bretagne
pendant deux mois donc on va tester le
bateau s'est un peu fait pied marin n'a
constaté que aurélien n'est pas le mal
de mer ça tombait très bien et ensuite
donc on a mis le bateau dans un
conteneur et on est parti aux îles
salomon dont les îles salomon ti leçon
géographie c'est dans le pacifique c'est
l'est de l'australie
j'étais au dessus de la papouasie
nouvelle guinée et donc on a décidé
d'aller à cet endroit là pour justement
le potentiel de vagues à découvrir et
donc on est parti durant trois mois donc
ça nous a le bateau nous avons offert
une liberté totale
donc on avait vraiment vous pouvez
vraiment aller on voulait selon d'autres
vies selon la météo selon le potentiel
de bonnes blagues à trouver toujours
dans une idée d'autonomie donc
alimentaire également au niveau 2
de nos batteries donc on avait un
panneau solaire sur le bateau et nous ça
permet de votre permis de voyager
pendant trois mois à travers les îles de
découvert des vagues ce qu'on peut
appeler parfaite pour nous donc surfer
de belles vagues vous voyez pas devant
des tubes on peut aller des deux côtés
donc c'était vraiment l'idéal de lessard
fait c'était vraiment idyllique
on va également partagé des moments
nautique et artistique avec les enfants
des villages et donc suite à ça on avait
on a donc on est rentré en france on a
réalisé également une autre websérie
donc cette fois ci on l'a appelée lost
the swell et donc c'est un plus tôt
également bien marché et notre envie de
repartir et est que plus grande parce
que lorsqu'on rentre de ce genre
d'aventuré ben on prend vraiment goût à
l'inconnu et à la découverte
et c'est vrai que quand on entre dans
notre confort et ben on apprécie le
confort on apprécie le canap la douche
le frigo rempli etc
mais il ya toujours un manque un manque
d'aventuré donc une fois qu'on a mis le
pied dedans c'est reparti donc on va
réfléchir on voulait faire quelque chose
de différent donc repartir différemment
pour toujours donc rechercher des vagues
un surf m est accessible avec un
abonnement de transport que le bateau
est donc pour ça on a opté pour des
vélos dont les vélos ces vélos ne s'est
pas n'importe quel vélo ce sont des facs
bike dont vous pouvez voir que les pneus
sont assez gros donc l'intérêt c'est de
pouvoir rouler sur des sols meubles donc
comme de la neige du sable et donc
l'idée c'était de justement d'avoir des
vagues auprès de nous donc de longer
la quote-part la plage et ainsi de
pouvoir découvrir de nouvelles vagues
potentiel voit dans un premier temps on
est parti on allonge et toute la côte
aquitaine donc d abord pour tester nos
mollets nos idées pour voir ce qui
allait et ce qui n'allait pas et tout
simplement voir si ça marche est donc vu
qu'on a toujours une notion d'autonomie
alimentaire et énergétique
eh ben on a pas mal de matériel à
trimballer donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
fait nos mains on s'est construit des
remarques on a amélioré d'avoir voir qui
existantes et ensuite on a décidé de
partir au gabon donc le gabon c'est un
petit pays sûr en afrique centrale et
qui a une portion de code 405 50 km qui
explorait où le gabon c'est un des
derniers un des derniers pays où il ya
des forêts côtières primaire de la
planète et donc de par cet aspect là ça
il y avait tous les ingrédients étaient
réunis pour trouver de bonnes vagues et
que l'aventuré soit au rendez vous donc
voilà ça c'est le panneau solaire qu'on
avait sur notre bateau qu'on a mis sur
la remorque de ronan donc ronan est en
charge donc de filmer mais également de
recharger toutes les batteries que ce
soit des appareils photos là cette fois
ci on avait un drone également nos
lampes torches et c'est ainsi que le
téléphone satellite parce que là on
avait un téléphone de sa tête pour
donner des nouvelles
et également pour le côté sécurité donc
avant de partir tout seul
on voulait avoir quelques conseils de
personnes avisées donc on s'est
rapproché de la pnc l'agencé nationale
des parcs nationaux du gabon est en gros
on a rencontré cet éco gardes qui
s'appelle alice et qui ont des parties
durant dix jours en immersion totale
dans la forêt donc il nous a pendant ces
dix jours l'a appris
les comportements des animaux les choses
à faire a pas faire ou à les trouver de
l'eau de la nourriture etc
ça c'était vraiment important pour nous
avant de partir seul à l'aventuré
donc on a rencontré des animaux donc là
par exemple c'était une petite approche
de baleines donc c'est la saison des
baleines à bosse passent devant la côte
donc on voulait aller vous voulez aller
les côtoyer donc là pour le coup elle
était un peu proche de moi j'ai pas le
temps d'avoir peur mais après ça je suis
vite rentrer sur le bateau ensuite on
m'a également aux côtés des éléphants
dont des éléphants de forêt qui ont le
sang chaud dont qui sont potentiellement
très dangereux parce qu'on les entend
pas dans la forêt et il voit pas grand
chose donc ils sont assez peu relou qui
charge tout ce qui bouge également
côtoyé des hippopotames des buffles et
des crocodiles donc ça c'est une
empreinte de croco qui moi je suis fait
du 44 et demi donc ça vous laisse
imaginer la taille de la bête et
également des gorille donc c'était
vraiment un endroit unique au monde où
tous ces animaux là se retrouver sur la
plage et donc il fallait faire en
conséquence donc en général on faisait
un gros feu dès 16h de l'aprem histoire
d'être sûr de ne pas être embêté une
fois dans l'eau c'était il y avait
également du monde donc pas de surfer
mais beaucoup de poissons également des
requins donc pas n'importe quel requin
des requins bouledogues dont causé les
pires pour les surfeurs on va essayer de
mettre toutes les chances de notre côté
avec différents systèmes entiers rocha
donc par exemple la combi gwen-ha-du là
donc c'est pas pour rappeler gwen-ha-du
mais c'est pour rappeler le serpent
corail car des serpents les plus
venimeux de la planète et apparemment
les requins auraient peur d'eux série or
là on avait également des espèces de
petites montré en fait c'est des
bracelets c'est des aimants qui
perturberaient les électro récepteurs
des requins qu'on a pu
sauf que de belles vagues c'était en top
on a découvert cinq spots de surf dont
certains vraiment un monde a ring on a
fait beaucoup de vélo beaucoup trop à
notre goût parce que nous on était quand
même là pour le surf
donc certaines journée on a roulé plus
de huit heures c'était vraiment
éprouvante
on était sur la latérite on a également
traversé des portions de forêt donc tout
en évitant les éléphants donc ça c'était
également assez tendue est assez
physique et de la plage ça donc les 450
km de plage on les a parcourus
maintenant les connais bien où l'idéal
c'était de rouler à marée basse ou le
sable était plus dure et mais bon des
fonds n'est pas le choix donc avec mon
rôle quand même à marée haute et c'était
vraiment très physique
voilà vous pouvez voir la petite sieste
de nono vers 16h et
voilà donc ça c'est l'atteindra qu'on va
surfer qu'on va trouver donc c'était
vraiment le graal la cerise sur le
gâteau c'est va qui déroule sur le coût
d'un kilomètre c'était ultra sauvage
vous pouvez voir la lagune à gauche qui
ont campé là bas en haut là dans la
savane que aurélien brûlé sans faire
exprès je vous inviterai à les voir la
websérie après et donc voilà donc
justement on est rentré en france il ya
l'année dernière mais ça c'était juillet
août septembre de l'année dernière on à
diffuser les épisodes forme de web série
on a également organisé des
avant-premières donc on a fait une
tournée d'avant-premières ou la première
c'était à brest évidemment donc on a
fait ça au quartz il y avait 1500
personnes
c'était vraiment impressionnant de voir
qu'autant de personnes étaient motivés
bien voir nos films de vacances et
ensuite on a fait tourner la france
qu'on est passé de bordeaux à paris
cherbourg saint malo et je vous en passe
et depuis là on revient tout juste de
l'île de la réunion donc on a été invité
au festival du film d'aventuré de la
réunion qu'on doit gagner et
voilà donc tout ça pour vous dire que si
vous avez un rêve
n'hésitez pas allez jusqu'au bout et
c'est tout faire pour y arriver ça vous
apportera sûrement de belles choses dans
votre vie en tout cas pour nous ça a été
le cas voilà merci
[Applaudissements]